Hey, GitLab Duo.
I need you to help me write a
script.
I want to process a video file, and
what I actually want is to save a
screenshot or image into a directory called frames
for every frame within the video file.
I don't know what language is best for
this, so you can choose. But I do
ask that you comment the code to help
me understand it.
Thank you.
Hello, and welcome back to the Rawkode Academy.
I'm your host, David Flanagan, although mostly known
across the Internet as Rawkode.
Today is a fun video.
I have the opportunity to play with and
explore GitLab Duo. This is GitLab's integrated AI
that allows you to write code faster.
I've decided that I want to do some
processing of my YouTube videos so that I
can use AI to generate thumbnails,
descriptions, summaries,
command extraction and a whole bunch more.
So I figured
let's put these two projects together
and see what we can come up with.
The first step was just to write some
script
that will generate
images from every frame in a video.
You've already seen the prompt.
Let's see the code.
Let's take a look. So just before we
go through this line by line, I want
to clarify that I am by no means
a Python developer.
I write Python a handful of times a
year and not very well.
I also wanna point out that none of
the tasks that we're gonna ask it to
do
are that
difficult to code yourself.
And I think that's where AI really excels
in the software development life cycle.
Saving your time from things that aren't hard
even if they are a little bit complicated,
allowing you to free up more time to
focus on novel solutions to more difficult
challenges.
With that being said, let's see what we
got.
So I asked
GitLab Duo to generate me some code. It
doesn't specify a language. It decided that Python
was a good decision
because of the OpenCV library.
And in retrospect,
I completely agree. It was a fantastic decision,
thank you.
I asked it to comment. Now the comments
aren't that useful, but then the code isn't
really that difficult to understand.
So I can kind of forgive it for
that.
As we give it more complicated tasks, hopefully,
it'll be able to elaborate on these comments
a little bit further.
However, we can see that it's kind of
divided our task up into three major steps.
One, a little bit of preparation.
First, you just configure where the video lives
and then create or ensure that a frames
directory exists.
And then opens the file and immediately starts
to loop through reading it frame by frame.
The last task is to save each of
those frames as a JPEG.
This is really easy with OpenCV,
but would I have been able to write
it as fast as GitLab Duo did?
No chance.
So let's make our first improvement.
This is nice but I don't like the
hardcoded video dot m p four even though
that is the name of our file.
Let's assume we're going to be able to
run this on any arbitrary file within my
machine.
Now again, I'm not a Python developer. I
don't know how to write a CLI with
Python. I don't even know how to process
argv.
I'm hoping GitLab Duo does.
So let's take a look.
Let's try and be
bold.
Let's select everything,
come over to our chatbot
and let's say
if I turn this
into a
man line application,
we want to ensure that the filename
can be passed in
by the
user.
Type in its code.
There we go. Let's copy this
and replace.
All this done is tell me or show
me, educate me that we can use sys.
Rv with a positional
indicator, in this case one, I'm assuming zero
is going to be the entire command line
and it's even telling me how to use
this which I think is a useful comment.
So
let's add this
to our code. Now we haven't actually run
this code yet
though maybe now is a good time to
test it out.
So here we are in the terminal.
We're going to run Python
frames dot py
followed by video dot m p four.
Now
now occurs to me
that we don't really have any print statements,
so there's a lot of assumptions about whether
this is actually running. So let's confirm that
by splitting our pane
and opening and finder.
And right away,
we can see
frames directory.
And if we just show this in preview
mode,
we can see the ticker scrolling along the
top as we run through hundreds
and I'm sure thousands
of frames.
Given that this video is probably about an
hour and a half long at a minimum
at 60 frames per second.
That is a lot of frame.
But we'll let the script get there.
And I won't bother going through it anymore.
So our script does work.
So let's use some movie magic and come
back in a moment when our frames are
rendered.
Okay, so that is now finished
and it did take a little bit of
time but we did get a 71,000
frames.
So that's 60 frames per second for a
little over a hundred minutes.
Now we don't want to spend a lot
of time during this video waiting on my
computer or cheating with movie magic.
Well, we're going to limit this to not
save every single frame.
And of course, we're not going to do
this manually.
We're gonna ask GitLab Duo.
So let's say
instead
of capturing
every frame,
let's capture one frame every ten seconds.
Alright. Now we have some updates to our
script. Now we're not gonna copy and paste
all of those and put it over the
top because we've been making modification.
We've got comments, we know how to run
the command,
and we can see here that it's right
back to hard coding our video dot m
p four. So we're just gonna select the
things that we need.
Now we can see that it imports math,
so let's bring that in
in alphabetical order
and we can see that it gets
frames
per second
after
the video capture.
So we're going to store that as FPS
two.
We then have a frame interval that we
wish to configure for us that is 10.
We want to skip
10 times the frames per second for one
image every ten seconds.
We're then just going to grab this if
statement
and indent
our code. This time, we only save the
JPEG
when we have a round ten
second
frame.
Let's go back to our terminal.
I'm going to remove our frames directory,
which on itself may take another while at
a 70,000
frames
and rerun
our script.
And hopefully for the last time we'll be
back in a moment.
Okay. Let's take a look inside of brems,
pipenet, wc and we can see that we
are now working with 572
file.
This is a lot less than a 70,000.
This is something we can work with on
a local machine.
So let's go back
to Versus Code.
Now my mission here is I want to
take the 600 frames and in fact let's
pop them open before we go back to
GitLab Duo
and take a look at our preview. Now
that's only 600, we should be able to
get an overview, at least a broad overview
of what happens on the stream.
We've got people, we've got Kubernetes commands, a
whole bunch of YAML,
Goes on and on and on. We've got
comments from the audience.
We've got lots of journal d, system d
commands.
I think we can have some fun with
this for sure.
Now wouldn't it be cool
if you were watching an episode of clustered,
and we could give you a list of
the commands
that were executed on the episode,
provided they were important or useful.
It would also be nice if we were
able to extract and highlight the error messages.
Now, of course, we could do this all
with manual work,
but we live in the age of AI.
We're using AI to write more AI.
Can GitLab Duo help me interact with other
AI models
to remove the laborious and tedious task of
watching every single episode
to describe
fine text and error messages, logs, and commands?
I sure hope so and we're about to
find out.
So I really have no idea what the
best approach here is.
We could continue using OpenCV,
which I do think has
text capabilities,
OCR,
or maybe we need to start shipping these
images to other AI models.
Let's ask GitLab Duo.
I want to extract
all the tech from the generated
images.
What is the best way
to do so?
Alright. So
it is suggesting we use PyTeseride,
which runs OCR
against the imaging.
Alright. And seems like a good first approach
and has given me some code.
We'll test that code in a moment, but
let's ask it a follow-up question.
Would
it be easier
or better,
better is a terrible word, or more accurate
to send these images
to an AI
model.
In fact, let's make it a bit more
specific
and let's just say to
OpenAI's
API.
And it says yeah. Okay.
Can I have code
to do that?
Please
remember to be nice to our AI overlords.
Oh, not enough details. Alright.
Let
ask our question again
and keep our contact.
Provide the code,
Duo.
No, please, because it made me ask twice.
Awesome.
And now we have code to interact with
OpenAI's
image to text API.
That is very
cool.
So let's try both approaches and see how
we get on.
Let's copy the code from the py tesseract
and call this local
image
to text
and paste it in.
This wants a single image. So right away
we need to make some modifications because we
are gonna have to loop over our directory.
However,
to test this maybe we will hard code
one image and see what the results look
like and we'll also do the same with
the OpenAI code.
So we'll call this remote image
to
tech.
And now we have two scripts that we
can work with, both of which want a
single image.
Then we'll ask it to change the code.
So let's find a suitable image.
If we go back to the terminal,
open frames and finder,
scroll
to the the the close my eyes here.
Dreadful. Although we at we do just want
to get text to be fair.
Alright. Okay. Here we have some good tech.
We have some pod output at the top.
We've got some hidden, but it's a crash
lit back off. You can't actually see a
complete version of that, except for maybe the
top array. I'm curious to see if the
remote model OpenAI would be able to inject
some knowledge into that. And we have a
command
and I have one error message about daemon
set cilium not found. I really want to
know if we can start to process this
with local OCR
at remote.
This image,
this frame here,
B4200.
And why can I not copy that image
name? I have no
eye dear.
Well, Mac just doesn't want me copying image
names. Alright.
V4200.
4 2 0 0. Alright. So
let's start
with low. I think that makes a lot
more sense.
Paste our comment,
to ls frame
and format is
frames
frame
three four two zero zero dot JPEG.
Easy.
We open it. We get the text, and
we're going to print it.
I guess there's only one thing to do,
run our local script.
That
was a face of pure joy.
That has done really, really well.
Awesome.
But generally just impressed that I haven't written
a single line of code myself and we're
doing OCR against frames generated from a video
file.
Such a great time to be a developer.
Okay, I'm so happy
with the local text and I know it's
gonna be a lot faster than using OpenAI
to process 600 images
that we're just gonna go with local.
So we're gonna update
scripts
to look over all the frames,
grab all the text and save it to
text file with the same name as the
frame.
Then we're gonna get GitLab Duo to send
that text to OpenAI
to try and help us understand all the
text that we've found.
Okay.
Update this code
to look
through every image
within the frames directory.
And
can
protect.
Alright.
So it's telling me that we can
use a clock.
So
we can remove this.
Then we open
the
I don't think anything else has to change,
but now we don't want to print the
text. But instead,
printing
the text.
Save it with the same
file name but with
a text extension.
Alright. So it's broken it down into tasks
for me.
Oh, we got this import statement that we're
going to need.
That's not changed.
This hasn't changed.
Now we're getting a base name.
And then we write.
Oh.
That it?
Oh, these imports are separate.
Check that. We got that one. Oh, we
got that one. Alright.
I like them in alphabetical order. Thank you
very much.
So
go up the frames directory,
get the base name,
do the OCR,
raise it to fail.
Could not be more simple.
Okay.
Before we run this,
which I'm sure we could do that would
work just fine,
let's take a look at some of the
quick actions provided
by GitLab
Duo.
Here we can ask GitLab Duo to refactor
our code.
Let's see what we get.
So here's one way to refactor the selected
code. It has now broken it down into
individual
tab,
which
will take.
Alright. So we have one function,
image detect, where we look over the globe.
Perfect. Alright.
I think we can refactor this further.
Let's see.
Image to text seems to do more than
one job.
And
and we refactor
further.
Yes, we can. Thank you.
Let's copy this code.
So now we've got our for loop of
our glob,
we got the base name, open the file,
we extract the text and we save the
text.
This
I'm quite happy with,
but let's see if we can run it.
So we run our local image to text
and if we look inside frames, all we
have are JPEGs right now.
So
local and
we'll split this.
Do we have any text files yet?
No.
Wow.
Alright.
Let's kill that.
And make sure we write it to the
same directory.
Oh, save tech.
Filename.
So we just need this
to use our frame there.
And we'll delete all dot text files.
Python
local
l l
print.
And let's just r g.
And now we're getting our text files.
So I'm not sure how long it's gonna
take to run the OCR and 600 files,
but let's just get by the bottom.
Alright. So that's now finished
and we have our 572
text files.
What we want to do is start to
send these to OpenAI
to do command extraction,
error message extraction,
and maybe we'll think of something else along
the way.
So let's start chatting to GitLab Duo.
We need a script.
Let's batch up
all the text files within the frames directory.
We need to ensure that each batch
does not surpass
the 28
token limit
of GPT
four turbo
preview.
Let's send
each batch
to OpenAI
and ask it to extract
command
and error
messages
and print them to the screen
with a discriminator.
Oh, we're getting the script.
Undo,
make me happy.
So we need
let's call this
OpenAItextdiscovery.py.
Alright. So we are importing OpenAI globin OS.
We still have a frames directory. We have
a max token limit. We know now that
we can do a gate NV
open AI token,
this is what it gave us before.
We've already imported away.
Now it's creating a creating batches,
which using the glob,
looping over, reading the bytes, concatenating the bytes
and oh yeah and we have a check
here to make sure that no batch goes
above
the token length.
When we have the batches, it's then enumerating
over them,
sending a completion
to da Vinci o three which will change
the model.
We have a prompt to extract commands or
error messages from the text
with a print statement at the end. So
it's not filled everything, asked for a discriminator,
that was maybe a bit of a long
shot but we'll tweak it to our needs.
We do however want to use GPT four
turbo
preview.
Now this is using the completion API.
I'm not that familiar with OpenAI stuff, but
I know there's
instructions,
completions, and chat.
I felt maybe we just chat, but I
guess if this is a one time thing,
not a big deal and I really just
want to run this and see if it
works.
So we've changed the model because we need
to context size with the large amount of
max tokens.
Max token response I guess we're only asking
for this I'm going to bump this up.
I don't know what the normal value is,
but let's just throw it up anyway
and we'll print the batch and we'll see
what we get back from API.
No idea right now if this is going
to work.
Oh, so that's the bit I broke.
We run it again.
Okay. So
OpenAI completion is no longer supported.
We either have to downgrade or fix this
to use the correct API.
Okay, so just in the interest of time
and I'm not sure how up to date
GitLab Duo's code samples are,
I did just from the OpenAI docs grab
this.
But I know I said I wasn't gonna
write a line of code
but I'm just gonna make my life easier
for the next few minutes.
And we're gonna do from OpenAI import OpenAI.
And it feels from what we've seen in
the error message and what I've seen as
a quick giggle there,
just that this API has changed drastically
for the one point zero release.
And I don't feel it makes it too
difficult to forget that too.
But now that we have
the right import,
we can create our client
like so.
And if I had called us the right
key, I wouldn't have to actually do this,
but it might just open AI token
and we can remove this. And then we
have our completion code here.
So how close were we?
Client
chat.
Completions create
messages.
Alright. That's format's different.
Role
user
content
f string
like so.
And the model, we're not using that one
so that's okay.
And if we don't need to set that
then let's not bother.
And
we're gonna add a break here so we
just do one batch and see the response.
Let's see if that helps things along.
Oh.
Oh, come on. Give me some commands and
enter messages.
Alright.
Okay. I think I know what this is.
Now because we changed this API here,
I wonder
what the response is actually going to be.
Let's do what
I do remember. The only thing I remember
from my Python days
is that we could do a PP print
PP print response.
We'll just comment this line out just now.
I just want to know
what we're gonna get.
Alright.
We have stuff and things.
I mean, we can't in our message saying
that can't do what I want it to
do,
but we're gonna tweak our prompt. So we
got a chat completion,
choices,
choice,
message
contents.
Alright.
It looks like it's this,
the little and it's not text.
It is message
content.
And I guess we can do that.
Maybe.
Again, my Python is abysmal.
Okay. And then let's tweak the prompt so
we try not to get an error message.
So let's try and tell it what we
wanted to do is extract
anything
that looks like a Linux
command
or error message
from this text.
And it's already slow, which is a good
thing we didn't use this for the image
to text. Right?
Alright. So we still got that choices message.
So I wonder if we could just paste
that in.
Help me out.
What does how do I fix this?
Alright. So it says that this is happening
because it is an object. Oh, yeah. Okay.
So
choice is zero. And I wonder if that's
gonna be the yeah.
Message
content.
I could do.
I'm sorry, but I cannot execute our parts.
Linux commands are directly.
If you have specific questions or needs about
Linux commands, Kubernetes concept, or error message, feel
free to ask.
Alright. So it seems to be struggling oh,
execute.
I don't say execute. Ah, okay. So I
think
we've had some sort of
safety filter
where it thinks I wanted to execute commands.
So we're gonna change our language.
We'll give it more context. This
is the output
from
my terminal
after executing
some Linux
commands.
What was good is it it said Kubernetes
and we hadn't mentioned Kubernetes yet. So it's
definitely understanding what's going on.
Can you tell me what command
I executed
and what error messages
I received?
Take 20.
Feeling pretty positive about this one.
Awesome.
So
awesome.
Okay. So it's definitely doing what we want
now. We bypass that filter about executing command
and we've got a ton of information.
Let's see if we can get this in
a structured format.
Return
your answer
in a structured
JSON
format.
Oh, cool. Alright.
We have JSON, we got all the executed
commands and the outputs, which we didn't even
ask for.
We can see p s, a u x,
scrap it for API. We got the response.
We got kubectl describe daemon set cilium. We
get the response.
We got some system controls, and then we
have a whole bunch of error messages down
there.
That is phenomenal.
Thank you so much. GitLab Duo and OpenAI.
Okay.
Let's go back to
GitLab Duo. I need some more help.
I
need a function
that creates
an in memory
equal light database connection.
Alright. Let's put our import to the top.
Now we have a create memory database.
I'll take it.
It's telling me how to use the database,
so let's put this into our main bit
of code.
Before
we start our batching,
let's get our connection to the database.
Now,
I need a schema
to store
command
and their output
associated
with a live
stream.
Let's see what we get.
Alright. It looks like we're not getting the
schema in SQL format,
so let's follow-up.
And I have this in SQL.
Please and thank you.
Let's copy that.
Let's just store this in main dot SQL.
Now it's already inserted and we don't need
an insert.
It's actually not give us any information about
a livestream.
I would like the command
associated
by foreign key
to livestream.
Alright. Let's grab our new version.
So now we have a livestream,
which has an ID, a name, a start
and end time. Perfect.
And we have command,
primary key, integers, date, title, etcetera. So now
we have a valid schema.
Let's write this
to our database connection.
How do I apply my
schema,
which I've
stored
in main dot SQL
to the in memory
SQLite
connection?
Alright. So the bit we need is command
execute web are open.
Like so.
So we open the file, we read it
in, and we do an execute.
Perfect.
Now what we want to do
is parse this response instead of printing it
and generate
inserts and text
to our database. How hard can that be?
Well,
when we printed out this, I noticed that
we got a markdown style wrapper on our
JSON.
We'll write a Python function
to remove
da da da code block
from a string. The code block
may
contain
a language
such as JSON.
This should be removed too.
Alright. So we got two Verition.
That's removing the entire block.
Yeah. We don't want to remove the entire
code block.
I want
the code,
but not the wrapper.
Please just remove
the the the JSON
and the the the from
the end.
I'll take it. Alright.
So let's put this new function
towards the top
and move our import further up.
I'm not entirely convinced this is correct, I
need this code to be tested.
So
let's select it
and say give me
test.
And it looks like we have a whole
bunch. Let's call this
code wrapper
test dot py.
Well, important to bet
is running a test against JSON
hello world.
Let's make sure it takes them off the
end too.
Or not, it's got test cases for that.
Okay. Remove opening tag.
That's pretty neat. The fact that we got
actually, it hasn't just written a bunch of
tests. It's written specific tests.
So we got opening tag,
closing tag,
both tag,
no tags.
Perfect.
Okay. So let's bring back our code and
now what we want to do
is
call remove code wrappers.
Our response
so that we get
some sort of JSON
like so.
How do I parse JSON
to a dict
in Python?
JSON Lloyd. Thank you very much.
So now
parses and we probably should call it JSON.
I'm sure there's an import JSON.
Yeah.
So let's import JSON.
And now we can print our deck data
which should have
you know what? Don't remember. Let's run.
Well, we don't want to run our TET.
Alright. So our output gives us a list
under executed command.
So
let's copy this structure.
Alright. Let's
get some help writing this to our SQLite.
Let's see.
Assuming
the following JSON
payload.
Right? A Python function
to look over
executed
command and insert
the command
into a SQL
ite
table.
Alright. What have we got?
Oh, we already have a connection.
Before command
and our deck data, execute a command.
Insert into commands command. Let's just check our
schema.
Commands command. Perfect.
Values
command.
Commit
and close.
Alright. Now we wanna be able to confirm
this, so we're gonna make one more change
to our script.
Change this connection
from memory
to local
file.
Let's see how far we get.
Python
open.
Don't.
What'd I get? What'd get? Oh, it's con.
Con. Con. Con.
Oh, no. It's because
this creates
cursor. And I didn't think that was important.
My fault, GitLab.
My apologies.
One last try.
Let's open Beekeeper Studio,
Or we can say SQLite.
Here's file.
Navigate my huge directory structure.
Video enrichment server.
RamesDB.
Open command,
and there we have it.
Awesome.
So that was a journey,
but I barely wrote a single line of
code.
Using GitLab Duo,
we were able to write a ton of
Python code.
First, processing a video file
and saving all the frames as JPEGs.
We then looked over all those JPEGs
extracting
the text.
We sent this text to OpenAI
where it classified commands
and error messages as well as the output
for the commands,
which we didn't even ask it to do.
GitLab Duo then wrote test cases for functions
that parsed and removed code block
and provided a database schema
and inserted our data into the database for
us.
Not bad for under a never's work.
That is a fairly chunky task made easy
by the power of AI
and GitLab Duo.
So go forth.
Get yourself some GitLab Duo and make your
life a whole lot easier.
Have a great day.